I covered the core of the checklist.
But there are a couple of things
I didn't walk you through.
Custom view controls and
custom accessibility services.
For any custom views that you create for
your app, you'll want to
implement the accessibility interfaces
to support the native features.
Beyond that, developers may build
their own accessibility services,
which can provide enhanced usability
features, such as audio prompting,
physical feedback, and
alternative navigation modes.
Accessibility services can
provide these enhancements for
all applications, a set of applications,
or just a single app.
This means that custom services you
build can be used by other apps, or that
your app might be able to use someone
else's custom accessibility feature.
So be sure to cover all of
your accessibility bases.